Apple has made one thing very clear it
will not put touch screens on Macs but
that doesn't mean others can't try this
is the neo node air bar and it claims to
turn any MacBook Air screen into a
touchscreen I can come to CES 2017
without trying it clip the magnetic air
bar to the bottom bezel plug it into the
USB port and boom you can control the
screen with your fingers
it doesn't actually create a touchscreen
though according to a senior vice
president at neo node it creates an
invisible light above the screen so when
the user touches the screen the sensor
realizes the touch event of course it
does just tap out an application icon
and it launches no special software
required you can swipe through photos
pan around maps rearrange icons into
folders and yes write and draw right on
the screen you can even add those
beautiful finishing touches to your
presentation and worried about closing
your laptop on the air bar don't worry
this happens if you try I was shocked at
how well it worked but it isn't perfect
especially when you consider that Mac OS
was designed for a mouse sometimes it's
a bit jumpy and it isn't even worth
trying to hit small targets on the
screen you can't scroll on webpages or
pinch to zoom though the company says
it's planning to add that soon plus it
only works with the 13-inch MacBook Air
the air bar will be out in March for $99
it's pretty cool maybe it'll even
convince those guys in Cupertino to
rethink that whole no touch screen on
Mac rule
you